this is a
Pepper Panic Saga level 170 walkthough video
this is one of the most difficult levels
from
the last episode and we think one of the most
difficult levels in the game
currently. the reason its so hard is
you have these two statues at the bottom
the board
that you can't hit with shockwaves,
it's also very in narrow in the middle so
it's hard to set up matches
so a lot of the time or structural
things around you also these timer
peppers with war
turns down the current council 0 income
pager
by and they block the statues kid that
worry it won't kill him
the explosion a shock wave soon begin we
were remove those timers
arm also look for these can capture here
we can shoot the middle pepper and it'll
make a shock wave that a good and
it said you so we have one was the top
in the
right now we're just going to take a
shot across the thirty set up
and I we set up another get here
we also want to think about growing the
colors that are sitting on top so we're
going to work on growing the purple
as well knowing it should be the gap and
I picked the top corner because I have
to purple a person at the bottom on the
right hand side
and that will
that could potentially help out later
because we can
explode both same time you get to you
his now I don't really wanna shoot the
gap anymore because it'll
make the timer go down to seven company
master mark together they take on the
lowest number
so we're not take this shot right now
there were disc and work on growing the
purple peppers to try to get them to
explore
couples that you grown the green with
the final two
it it's down the number two right now on
the
the green peppers are very close to each
other so there's never a chance to
actually exploder
know if if we have to we're going to
have to take the shot in the middle so
first we should probably grow some the
purples a little bit more so
in hopes that we can get actually get a
chain reaction because
if we haven't the number for paper
sitting at the bottom middle term stone
forget through the
there's really not a lot more options at
this point
we're gonna get an explosion to make the
for peppermint
so that over everything so
that there'll probably explode any way
that this poor alright that's a pretty
good result we just have one
petrified per se on top of the page
statue
on there's no more time is left
so now we want to grow green
or or to try to %uh get rid of those
I want to explore the purple here though
the way
there were a lot of other matches
personal but now
we want to grow the breeder the
pick the shock with a clear calm because
it doesn't really upset this metric here
that we have
with the green and sometimes getting the
those grown pepper the or like earlier
way or how about later because
you don't have a bunch and simmer
we also do we also would like to set up
a gap at the bottom but as you can see
it's pretty
they've got enough we manage this red
one
will get agreement from the top two drop
down we should be able to
explode the screens now yeah the
that clears up the first Pittsburgh
paper and
there's not a whole lot of growth on
that side anyway so loosen the two
papers for the
eric is no big deal now we have a gap on
the right hand side
to make another shock wave and
we want to grow wanna grow our red
so we can treat this shock wave going
down and then we also have a gap for the
for the cream there that we might be
able to set up another shock wave year
now we can rest and fluids that this for
ever met here
in yet another shock with go down so now
we have a
for peppermint at the bottom that
destroyed the
the stone upper
and now really all we have to do is grow
our Reds
we have honeymooners was growing peppers
until we start
the by a chain reaction though and the
the complete the level
so that there was some those a lot
simpler than it usually is
but honestly you know we set up a lotta
moves there and we actually gave
ourselves a great chance to get past it
by
taken care the timers early so when you
play this level
you know if all the tension in our pool
guy
and just remember like you know they're
going to be times when
the stone peppers are going to stack up
but if you're always
thinking internet setup moves like that
you can
you actually get through it with quite a
few I'm sitting in that column
arm hopefully this will help you
you know Plano your moves in leave the
level and
will be making more videos a more level
guide soon for thanks for watching